[Musique]
l'actualité des tournages ne conduisent
aujourd'hui à joinville ou jean
christophe averty essaye de trouver une
écriture peut être plus simple moins
agressive qui leur considéré avec la
majorité des téléspectateurs et bien une
procession bien changé depuis cinq ans
je continue à déplaire et je le déplore
malheureusement tant que je pourrai
faire les variétés comme je les aime
quand j'ai qu'on soit je continuerai
parce que je pense que de temps en temps
il faut qu'un metteur en scène quitte à
déplaire à tout le monde continue à
chercher quelque chose quitte à ne rien
trouver ce qui est mon cas à part est
apparemment d'après les critiques
la plupart des spectateurs qui ont
utilisé chez eux ne la respecte pas et
la considère comme un véhicule à théâtre
un véhicule à music hall un véhicule à
cinéma est absolument pas comme on n'a
pas une télévision
tant et si bien que les gens sont ravis
de voir un chanteur derrière un micro
sur une scène musicale de voir les
acteurs sur une scène de théâtre de voir
des films bon ou murray avait une voix
rarement la télévision on peut dire qu'à
la base
au départ il ya une recherche
personnelle pour essayer d'intégrer
un acteur un danseur un chanteur un
écran de télévision les critiques les
plus acerbes que je reçois c'est sa
bouche trop effectivement ça bouge trop
et je le veux comme ça parce que
j'estime que la télévision n'est pas un
art de tout repos on doit pas pour la
télévision bien assis dans son fauteuil
il faut protester
remuez se secouer bref à voir en sorte
une des réactions brutales devant son
poste
la télévision est un instrument qui va
vous trouver chez vous il faut donc
qu'il tienne sa réputation il faut se
secouer les gens chez eux
maintenant on dit également que je sers
mal les chanteurs que je les cache
derrière une mise en scène exubérante
enfin en tant que moi qui aime bien les
chanteurs au bout d'un quart d'heure
quel qu'il soit talentueux soit-il il
devient extrêmement rasoir s'est on les
montre comme dans les émissions que vous
n'y a absolument aucune recherche de
présentation au bout d'un quart d'heure
moi j'ai la nausée c'est bien que les
décors et la mise en scène
autrement dit l'intégration télévisées
ou télévisuelle d'un chanteur dans
l'écran toilettes comme un nid cuisson
c'est de l'herald isme autrement dit il
ya un symbole l'attend au tour du
chanteur fer forgé par un décor ou formé
par une tare une suite de montage
autrement dit elle essaie de traduire
visuellement ce qui n'est que jamais que
la reproduction d'un disque autrement
dit il savait intégrer le chanteur dans
son décor et faire du décor l'élément
visuel de la chanson le fond comment de
leur forme
ça revient à la surface comme ça c'est
sociable l'enterrement de qu'en déduit
ces daims et une chanson caricaturale
des enterrements la nouvelle orléans
alors donc la chanson du textuellement
nous étions 200 à l'enterrement de
cornée du sort donc 200 figurants ça va
de soi j'aurais évidemment vers les
dessins petits bouts de papier mais je
pensais qu'il était drôle de serre une
fête macabre à la fin d'un show qui
prétendait est une distraction
les champs elysées
[Musique]